>>> TONIT
NG E ONSU
DIVORCE SINCE 2019.N IS
BILLTHR AND CEO ANeporter: THEYN
SHWO
DEVELOPMENT.
>> I WAS NEW T A LOT OF MEN THE
D, KSTIL, YOU .UTr: AFT KNOW, S
R SUSE, CERTAINLY MY  YOU WE SAO
IWAKE WOW AND
S GOIN HAPPEN?
>> Reporter: AFTER7
MARRR RP
IS A SOURCE  GREATNTREEGESE ISG?
MELINDA GATES WAS CONCERNED OVER
EPSTEIN. ND'
>> IT SEEMGATES MET WITHPSTEIN1
E WITH, AND A GATES
WAS T HAPPY AT THE TIME.
eporter: THAT SOUR
ER EMPLOYEE OF TNDA GATES MADEE
KNOWN TO HER HER FRU
TO BILL GATES ANT
FEEL RELATIONSP  JEFFREY
EPSTEIN, ESPECIALLY SINCLIS IS F
EPSTEIN, YOU KNOW, HAD HIS
ISSUES, D WASED BULL GATES TIES
TO THE "NEW YORK TIMES",
BEGINNININ 201GASTEIN ON NUMERO
CE S
LTYRYFFEREND
INTRIGUING, ALTHOUGH IUL
ME THE TIMES REPORTED.
A GATES SPOKE PEONRI
E
G ACQUAINTANCES UE DECOREPSTE
INET MR.
WAONVEY INRER
BILL GATVER MEETING
PSINOGNIZE ERROR IME
SO.
IN 2S SAID HE DID NOT
VEIP OR
FRIENDSHIP WITEPSTEI
IT NOT CLEAR WHETHER GATES S
RELATIONSHIP WITH EPSTEIN PLAYEN
>> IMELINDA, IT'ULY EQUAKEHASHE
INTERESTEDSCIENCE.
SHE'S BETTER WITH PEOPLE THAN .
>> Reporter: ANNOUNCING THE SPL,
BILL A MELINDA GATES SAID
QUOT N WE WEOGETHER AS A CE  OF.
FOR SPACE AND PRIVACY FOR
OUR FAMILY A BEGIN TNAVIGATE TH.
ACCORDTO